Hey, I'm Janet. Boom.
Rod. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio on our
subject right now is cities.
So far we've tried to pin down the
character of a place with math or with a
story or with some music.
Woo.
But it's like trying to take a snapshot
of something that's growing and changing
all the time and that feeling
that skip had up on the rooftop,
like the city with breathing. Maybe
the city really is like a living
thing. Well, yes. In some ways.
That's exactly right. The evolve, the
grow. Think about it as Jeff West,
every day, every minute,
incomes, energy, food, trucks,
water people, out goes
garbage ideas, song stories,
people energy in, energy
out, energy, energy,
Huh?
That's just what a city needs to
do. Such Jeff port metabolize food,
so to speak, because without that,
organisms and sitters and so on,
we'll simply do carry. So
how does a city stay alive?
What does it really take
for a city to grow? Well,
that question got me thinking about New
York and led me to a place I've been
wanting to go for a while.
[inaudible] to hear the
reverb a little bit.
Where are you underground?
Oh, 100 feet under
Brown
[inaudible] so this is the sound of
one of New York City's water tunnels.
I'm standing in it. It's
exactly what you would imagine.
It's about nine feet wide, nine
feet up, perfectly polished cement.
And uh, it seems to just go forever.
[inaudible]
so this is basically a,
like you might call it a smaller artery
inside the city's circulatory system.
When this is online, in a couple
of months, it will pump up to
290 million gallons a day.
[inaudible]
something like that, which is an awesome
thought in the literal sense. Yeah,
it's a, when you walked through
the streets in Manhattan,
this is Catherine Mallen from the
Department of environmental protection.
These water tunnels are anywhere
from 200 to 800 feet below your feet.
They just there and they're silently
there. And when you turn on your tap,
can you take a drink?
You are basking in a daily convenience
that is born from blood, sweat,
and death. To explain.
You really have to go back to a
time when there were no tunnels.
This would be 1790 1800 or so around
that time says historian Diane Galicia in
New York's population was
booming. It tripled in 20 years.
And you suddenly at 100,000 people all
getting their water from the same spot,
a large freshwater pond called the collect
than they had pigs running around by
the hundreds and the chamber pots out
in the streets and there were livestock
and Lower Manhattan. At the
time people had cows for milk.
And so when they died, they
had to do something with them.
So often she says they'd throw their dead
cows and everything else in the pond,
the same pond they were
drinking from, right? No,
not surprisingly. As the city grew,
people got sick in 1798 there
was this yellow fever epidemic,
killed a couple of thousand people and
cholera and typhoid city officials were
like, this has to change. And uh,
as if to accentuate the point
in 1835, it was this huge fire.
The fire department rushes out to
put out the fire. But they can't.
It was in December and the rivers froze
and they couldn't get water to the
fires. If you don't have water to
fight the fire, the city burns down.
It's pretty simple. Yeah, 700 buildings.
So that's our starting point in
New York City that could not grow.
And by the way, the guy we just heard
John Chick Donahue, he's the sand dog.
So part of the long line of guys who
blasted New York out of its poopy pawn
phase and into its future. You ask your
question why? Why are you guys cold?
Sandhogs why wouldn't you be calling
tunnel blasters or earth movers or
something that's more, do you have any
idea where that name came from? Yeah,
it comes from the dictionary really,
and I loved the look on people's
faces when they asked me that and I,
that's the answer.
It's described in Webster's dictionary
as a laborer who digs or works in sand
originals sandhogs with the soft
ground guys compressed there.
That's where he didn't know to backup
for a second when the city decided to
scrap the pond in favor of
clean water from upstate.
If faced a couple of challenges,
and this is also true.
When they decided to build a
subway system, namely nature,
like how do you for example,
build a tunnel under a river?
Well they were sandhogs,
Jamie, Dan, they did
little eat dog with what
we call a muck sticks,
shovels on the ribbon,
50 60 a hundred feet under the bottom
of the river. Men with shovels,
excavating ground. That's Nick's
socal. I'm a tunneling engineer.
Generally it's a dark, dank
place. Now the obvious engineering
problem is that the river bottom,
which is now above their heads is
soft sands and silts and gravels.
How do you keep that from
not falling on your head?
That's when a compressed air started
being used. The basic idea says, nick,
is it these huge pumps would basically
pump air into the tunnels at such
pressure that it would basically
push the ceiling up. Exactly.
So the mud doesn't cave in on the
compressed there holes that thing from
collapsing in on.
Usually the engineers on the shore had
to get the pressure just right says
chick. Cause if they didn't,
you get this absolutely terrifying
situation that is maybe the best cocktail
party story ever. We used to give an
award, we haven't given it many years.
We call it
the Marshall may be award
hello,
that were doing one of
those tunnels. Brooklyn.
The men are weapon to face
in a tunnel and digging away
very suddenly
is a blowout in the face of the wallet.
Puncture hole develops tiny at first,
but it quickly becomes bigger and bigger
until it's the size of sort of like an
eye. Then a whole head and all the
compressed air rushes into that.
Oh, it would be like if you
shot a hole through an airplane.
Alia with shawl hats are flying into this
whole lanterns shovels than a guy goes
into the whole a guy. Yeah, a human being
into the hole and another guy, boom.
Then a third, the third guy must've
been the luckiest sand hog in the world.
This is an article from the New
York Times as I struck the mud,
it felt as if something was squeezing
me tighter than I'd ever been squeezed
before. We blew through
all at 60 feet and walked
through the Redmond.
Yup.
To the surface. The pressure
blew him right up into
the, yeah, you tell me.
I was thrown about 25 feet
above the water when I came out,
but I don't remember that.
That's remarkable. Anything
back down and landed right alongside
a police boat in the one in the world.
So they took him to clean
them up. He went home.
He came to work the next day.
That's why they gave him the award.
That's why the award is
now. I'm not kidding you.
In the early days,
no one kept track of how many people
died building New York's tunnels the
number. It's probably in the thousands.
So wait, this, this right here,
this plaque that we're looking
at, this flack was a donated.
This is Richie fits in and
sees the current head of
the San hugs union and we're
standing in front of a big stone
plaque with two dozen names
in memory of all the, uh,
people that we lost in tunnels in
New York City since 1970. You know,
since we started keeping records,
small little photos commodity.
Later he showed me a picture,
which really underlined the point.
It's a picture of him on his first
compressed air job. Oh Wow. Look at that.
This is myself.
He's 19 he's huddled with five other guys
and they're in this crowded tunnel and
they're all black, was said, and
he points to each guy in turn
dead, dead, dead, dead,
had cancer still alive, still alive.
If you ask any of the
sandhogs why they do this,
mostly they'll tell you
what we, we've got to,
the city can't grow without its tunnels,
but you also get answers like
this from chick. If he says,
when you're down there and it's pitch
black and you're just walking away
and yeah, 600 foot under Manhattan,
you're approximately
30th street or something,
you're in the middle of the
greatest city in the world.
Nobody even knows you exist.
Nobody has it. Nobody has a clue.
It just
beautiful.
It's just that it's a weird place.
It's like being on a planet somewhere.
He says when he's literally in this
rock that is half a billion years old,
he sometimes feels
very humble.
Yeah, we're in the middle of the
art. Then you know how this is.
You want to see nature. It is
a romantic way of saying it.
A, the human reality of it
is, here's Richie's taken.
Remember when you were a kid and they
used to give you the Anne farms in the bay
and farms were big. We are ants.
Ants is so fricking many of them that if
you got a squish a few and if they got
to use each other to step over each other
to, to, to, to keep that whole thing,
that's it. That doesn't sound very grand
the way you're putting it like that.
It's reality. Our job is to conquer
nature. He says, plain and simple.
We're builders. Human beings
are builders and collectively
there's nothing that we can do.
Hmm. How often?
October 14th, 1842 oh, it
was a huge celebration.
Hundreds of thousands
of New Yorkers. Line,
Broadway was firing of cannons and the
ringing of Church bell fireworks even,
and at the end of it all says Diane,
everybody gathered in City Hall Park
and the turned a big fountain on and
[inaudible]
water shot 50 feet into the air.
New York City. We'd never be the
same. No can finally be a city.
But here's where you start to wonder
a little bit about the real legacy of
cities. What you see almost immediately
after this moment, according to Diane,
is that water usage skyrocketed.
Suddenly you had indoor plumbing.
All the new buildings were being
outfitted with water closets and kids were
playing in the hydrants all day
long. And to make a long story short,
just 10 years later, the
city is out of water again.
So they get to build more
tunnels and then more.
And if you follow the water and
those tunnels, backup state,
you see that the city is gobbling up
reservoirs, one after another, dozens,
which made it had to kick people off that
land, well then called eminent domain.
Their villages would have to be bulldozed
and burned cemeteries fruited do you
see what's happening?
I mean you could see this city that
we live in as a kind of monster.
It's just always hungry,
eat, eat, eat, eat, eat. And
because like, like there is
another logic available here.
Like if you took all the people in
New York City, all those New Yorkers,
you know, if,
if you had every inhabitant in New York
City suddenly left New York City and
moved to small towns all across America,
you would need a ton of
resources to make that possible.
That's Jonah lira again,
by the way. So in a sense,
New York City saves lots of forests, saves
lots of water. And the reason why,
well that takes us back to
Jeff and Lucia's ideas about
cities. Well I suppose,
cause it all started years ago,
Jeff at the time was studying
this time was living things.
Let's go back to biology for a moment.
He looked at a huge variety of creatures
and for each one he collected data from
its metabolic rate to the length
of it, say how quickly it breathes.
And he discovered something kind of
fascinating about creatures as they grow
bigger and picker. If you
double the size of an organism,
you double the number of cells
that need to be sustained.
You would therefore expect that the
energy you need to supply would double.
You've doubled the number of customers,
so to speak. Yeah, yeah. No, no.
That is not the case. Instead of doubling,
it needs less energy per unit cell
to sustain the whole organism.
So there is a kind of notice
way. Second, that means that the,
that the cell is somehow
doing more with less. Right.
Does that also mean though
that an elephant cell somehow
is more efficient than
mouth cell? That's correct.
Huh. And Jeff says,
the way they do that is pretty
simple. They just move slow.
I process energy at a slower
rate. So if you take a mouse cell,
a cell that lives in a mouse and
does its work, brings in resources,
spits out the waste,
bring in more resources,
spits out the way it
does this to a particular
beep.
But now says Jeff, if you
listen to an elephant cell,
okay.
[inaudible] means no
poem. It's moving
obviously slower. So it's using
less energy in a given moment,
which makes it efficient. What
does that have to do with cities?
Turns out cities work kind
of the same way in cities.
You see the same kind of efficiency
when it comes to infrastructure,
electricity, length of roads, lengths
of pipes, lengths of electrical, cables,
saline, how much gas is consumed
is the point. The bigger the city,
the less roads you need per capita. What
is per capita mean anyways, per person,
per person, the less electrical
cable lines you need per capita,
the less gasoline stations you need
per capita, et Cetera, et cetera.
So every unit of pipe carries
more water and more sewage.
Every line of electrical wire
carries more. It did. Jeff,
does that mean then that if, uh,
if I moved to a bigger and bigger city,
do I in a sense become greener
the bigger the city I live in?
Yeah, that's a very interesting question.
And this is where Lewish and Jeff,
I think the case is still a
little bit out. And even Jonah,
it gets complicated when you ask,
are people more or less efficient?
This is when everybody starts to
throw in all of these caveats and
qualifications, all the variable
qualifications and ambulations and
prognostications. Distillations.
Let me just tell you what I think.
I think you'd better. All right.
We all love to talk about how green
we are when we live in cities.
This is something everybody in the city
talks about, right? Because we are,
because we take the subway and the
bus, we don't draw and driving. Right.
The most energy consuming
thing. Listen to me,
the analogy that you just gave
me, it does not work. Okay.
You said that cells as they go from
small bodies to big bodies slow down.
Yeah. Well cities, the opposite
happens. Of course as cities get bigger,
each individual unit in that city moves
faster. So thank you Jonah. We speed up.
It's true. We learned this earlier
and this is not trivial. Okay.
Cause as we speed up, we bump into
more people. We have more ideas,
we invent new things, we want more things.
We want more or more of
your tastes. New Ideas.
More interactions. More human
friction. More. More choices. Yeah,
a better life. That's what
a city is all about. I,
is there anything wrong
with that? No, not at all.
But there's all I'm saying is there's
a cost to it that we don't acknowledge.
Western Betancourt did this back of the
envelope calculation where it's long
been known that a body at perfect rest,
if you lie on your bed all day in a coma,
you will consume and buy
90 watts of electricity.
That's your basal metabolic rate.
If you're a hunter gatherer living
in some tribe in New Zealand,
you will consume about 240
watts of electricity every day.
Energy just simply to stay alive,
plus the energy you need to hunt them.
However, if you are living in America,
the wattage required to drive your car,
run your computer, make your
clothes, air conditioning,
being able to go to movies on and on and
all the various things that constituted
our life. If you add all those up,
your lifestyle requires about 11,000
watts of electricity every day. So that's,
that's more energy than a blue whale
requires. Now, some of you listening,
particularly if you're engine
deer, you may think, wait a second,
why are you calling these watts?
When his power through his system power
through a human, call them jewels.
It's the technically correct word.
And then you'd be right, wouldn't you?
But the numbers are the same. So
let's, we'll just call them lots.
So one way to look at what cities have
enabled us to do is basically live like
300 and million blue whales in America.
Are you sure that cities are
causing this development?
That it begins and ends with cities
and you can't assign it all to cities.
But that psychology of wanting
more, that's a city psychology.
It's why people come to cities.
And then the lifestyle that grows up
around that gets broadcast out on TV and
radio shows and movies, which are
city industries to the country.
And if you just take a
historical look at this,
like the last 300 years have seen more
and more consumption, right? Yeah.
And that trend says Jones,
it's grown in neat parallel
with the growth of cities.
Cities have enabled that kind of
growth. Even if you guys are a right,
we know that half the planet already
is living in cities, 80% of America.
So yes, there are more people.
I'll agree with that. More choices,
asking for more consumption, more
energy, more, more, more, more, more.
Even if that's so cities,
because they are ingenious
and they come up with all these new ideas.
Maybe cities will solve the
problem right now. Jets,
someone somewhere in Calcutta is about
to invent the super light bulb elevator
telephone pipe that will make it possible
for another 200 trillion people to
live together in peace, harmony,
and beauty until the next round.
All right?
You go ahead and claim to that optimism
and you of course can go hang yourself
in corner, so we'll be right back.
I remember crawling. That's dad.
He was Radiolab.